Traductor: Nerea García Garmendia
Revisor: Javi Garriz
Voy a comenzar haciéndoos una pregunta:
¿Por qué comemos carne?
La comemos en todo momento,
de muchas maneras diferentes.
De hecho, para muchos es
la máxima experiencia culinaria.
El ser humano,
como especie omnívora que es,
obtiene sus nutrientes de muchas fuentes,
y una de ellas es la carne.
En una dieta saludable y equilibrada,
se recomienda que el 35 % de las calorías
ingeridas sea en forma de proteína.
Esta proteína tiene
unos componentes básicos
que se llaman aminoácidos,
que nos ayudan a regular
muchos de los aspectos de nuestro cuerpo:
ayudan a construir y regenerar tejidos,
y a sintetizar hormonas que nos ayudan
en el metabolismo, como la insulina.
Ahora vamos a hablar de números.
Según la ONU, somos 7.300 millones
de personas en el mundo,
y de media, cada una de esas personas
come 76 gramos de proteína al día.
Si hacemos las cuentas,
sale que tenemos que producir 202.000
millones de toneladas de carne al año,
y estamos hablando de hoy,
si nos vamos a 2050,
hablamos de 9.700 millones de personas,
y en 2100 seremos
11.200 millones de personas.
El ser humano, un ser inteligente,
creó un modelo para poder abastecer
a todo el planeta:
el modelo de la ganadería intensiva,
que nos ha estado alimentando
durante mucho tiempo.
Pero seguimos creciendo
y demandando comer carne,
y este sistema ha llegado a los límites,
está en situación de sobreexplotación.
Lo estamos viendo en nuestro día a día
en diferentes ámbitos.
Estamos expuestos a riesgos sanitarios,
exposición a pandemias: gripe aviar,
fiebre porcina, vacas locas...
Tenemos riesgos para la salud:
el 80 % de los antibióticos
que se producen en el mundo
no son para consumo humano,
sino de ganado.
Esos antibióticos posteriormente
se quedarán en la carne que ingerimos
sin ningún tipo de control,
y además creamos resistencia a ellos.
Con lo cual, uno de los mayores
inventos y descubrimientos de la medicina
se está quedando con poca eficacia.
Además, hay una dosis de hormonas
que estamos ingiriendo, poco controlada,
y también tenemos acceso a carnes
con un gran contenido en grasa,
que afecta a nuestras enfermedades
cardiovasculares.
No nos podemos olvidar
de cuestiones éticas.
Estamos preocupados hoy en día
por el bienestar animal;
en esta sobreeplotación
hay mucho sacrificio y sufrimiento animal
que ya está en tela de juicio.
Además, es una de las primeras causas
de emisión de gases de efecto invernadero,
tiene el 14,5 % de la cuota global,
es superior a la cuota del transporte,
con aviones y barcos incluidos.
Y además, es la primera causa
de deforestación del planeta,
porque de media, cada animal,
para hacer un 1 kg de carne,
tiene que consumir 6 kg de pienso,
lo que quiere decir
que hay que hacer mucho pienso.
Muchos de esos campos que vemos
cuando vamos por las carreteras
son para pienso animal,
no para consumo humano.
Si además de esto le añadimos
la contaminación de acuíferos y suelos
que se produce alrededor
de las granjas de ganadería intensiva,
tenemos un problema grande a nivel global.
Muchos innovadores de la alimentación
están intentando
poner soluciones y alternativas.
Por ejemplo, cómo están cambiado
las hamburguesas vegetales.
Las hemos visto durante bastante tiempo
en los supermercados,
más orientadas a un público
vegetariano o vegano,
porque a los carnívoros
no les apetecía mucho probarlas.
Pero hoy en día tenemos nuevas opciones
para atraer a un público carnívoro
e intentar reducir
el consumo de carne animal.
El problema es que la proteína animal
y la vegetal no son iguales.
Se mide la cantidad neta útil de proteína
que podemos absorber y utilizar,
y el sistema digestivo del cuerpo humano
está preparado para metabolizar
proteínas animales,
pero la proteína vegetal
le cuesta un poco,
con lo cual no podemos sustentar
toda esta demanda adicional que habrá
con proteínas vegetales.
En 1931 Winston Churchill,
como buen visionario,
ya predijo que el ser humano
iba a escapar del absurdo
de crear un pollo entero
si solo queríamos comernos
la pechuga o el ala.
Y 88 años más tarde, eso ha llegado.
Viene de la mano
de la ingeniería de tejidos.
Para quien no esté
familiarizado con este término,
es una rama de la medicina regenerativa.
Trata de hacer
reconstrucciones funcionales
para reparar tejidos corporales u órganos.
Algún ejemplo de esto,
que seguro que ya habéis visto,
son los injertos de piel,
cartílago, tráqueas...
Esto ha existido durante mucho tiempo,
pero solo hoy tenemos
las herramientas suficientes
para poder pensar en crear
tejidos musculares, que es la carne,
en grandes cantidades y elaborarlos
en forma de productos alimenticios.
¿Cómo funciona la técnica?
Imaginaos un animal, vamos a visualizar
un animal en perfectas condiciones,
cuanto mejor esté, mejor será
la muestra que vamos a sacar.
Una vaca, un pollo, un cerdo...
Le extraemos una muestra de carne,
por ejemplo, de una pata.
Esa muestra de carne sabemos que tiene
tejido muscular, venas, grasa, nervios...
Hay técnicas muy conocidas en medicina
que te permiten aislar las células
que tú quieres de estos tejidos.
Como a nosotros nos interesa la proteína,
porque queremos dar
una buena cantidad nutritiva de ella,
vamos a aislar las células musculares.
Esto se hace en un periodo
muy corto de tiempo,
con lo cual esos tejidos siguen vivos.
Esos tejidos los puedes colocar
en un ambiente controlado
y favorecido para ellas,
que quiere decir que les vamos
a poner en un medio acuoso
que tiene proteínas, aminoácidos,
sales minerales, aire para vivir,
y ellas siguen creciendo
y haciendo su función.
Y la función de las células musculares
es hacer tejido muscular
lleno de proteínas.
De esta manera, si después se colocan
en un tipo de fermentador o biorreactor
que simule el cuerpo del animal,
puedes obtener una masa muscular
libre de grasas si así lo deseamos,
sin necesidad de haber matado
ningún animal.
Para que os hagáis una idea, de muestras
sacadas de un cerdo durante un año
podemos tener
la misma capacidad productiva
que de 400 cerdos teniendo una matanza.
Es una carne que respeta
el bienestar animal,
y que, como habéis visto con los números,
reduce mucho el consumo de recursos,
y además no tiene ningún tipo
de exposición a pandemias;
los animales que utilizamos
para sacar las pruebas
están en perfecto estado de salud,
y a lo largo del proceso no tienen
ningún tipo de exposición
ni a virus ni a bacterias.
¿Cómo está el panorama global?
Aquí tenemos unos cuadrantes
que nos explican cómo estamos.
Abajo tenemos la ganadería tradicional,
que está en los límites de sostenibilidad
y no puede seguir aumentando
la producción.
Tenemos las alternativas que surgen
para ayudar a satisfacer esta demanda,
las alternativas de origen vegetal
emulando esa carne
para traer y bajar un poco el consumo,
y las alternativas sostenibles
de producción de proteína animal
por medio de lo que se llama
la técnica de carne cultivada.
¿Cómo de real es esto?
En 2107 éramos cinco empresas;
hoy en día somos 25.
Esto es imparable, ya es una realidad.
Os he marcado en rojo
las que pertenecen a la UE.
No sólo están naciendo empresas
que producen carne cultivada;
la industria cárnica está apoyando
a esas empresas
porque son conscientes de la falta
de recursos que tenemos
para seguir alimentando
a la población del planeta.
No solo en la industria cárnica,
sino en todas las industrias asociadas
a la cadena de producción y distribución
de este tipo de productos.
Y una cosa más importante,
o igual de importante:
los gobiernos están apoyando
estas iniciativas
y desde las autoridades regulatorias
están preparados para regularlas.
En la UE, la autoridad que valida
los alimentos que comemos es la EFSA.
En 2015 en su artículo 2283,
por si alguien tiene curiosidad
y pudiera verlo,
se describe el uso de 'novel foods'.
Un 'novel food' es toda aquella comida
que no se ha utilizado
frecuentemente desde 1997.
Pues en 2017 ya se aprobó
dentro de la categoría de 'novel food'
los alimentos provenientes
de cultivos celulares.
La UE ya está disponible ya
para regular este tipo de alimentos.
Estos son los primeros alimentos
que se han hecho.
Podéis ver diferentes modelos,
hay carne de pollo, cerdo y vaca.
Y nos podemos imaginar cómo será
la fábrica de la carne cultivada.
Si lo que estamos acostumbrados a ver
es esto, que es la ganadería intensiva,
esto es lo que vamos a ver.
Esto no es nada raro, ya existe
en la industria de la alimentación,
realmente todos los yogures
y productos lácteos que comemos
vienen de fermentadores
o biorreactores como estos.
El vino se hace en fermentadores así,
y las levaduras de la cerveza viven ahí.
A estas alturas de la película
os estaréis preguntando:
¿Y qué opina el consumidor final?,
que somos todos nosotros.
Nosotros, obviamente,
también nos lo preguntábamos,
e hicimos un estudio de aceptación
del consumidor, a nivel nacional.
Se hicieron unas encuestas
en las ciudades más pobladas de España,
y lo que obtuvimos fue muy gratificante,
porque estamos mucho más preparados
de lo que pensamos.
Entre en sí y el no,
siempre ganan los créditos del sí,
y la gente está dispuesta
a consumir este tipo de carne.
Lo que tienen claro todos,
los síes y los noes,
sobre todo un 80 % de la población
sabe que en cinco años
esta carne va a estar
en los lineales del supermercado.
Y con toda esta información,
podéis pensar lo que queráis.
Los consumidores de carne
podéis incluso engañaros,
seguir pensando que vamos
a comer carne como hasta ahora,
de manera indefinida.
Los vegetarianos y veganos, incluso
podéis tener una dieta más flexible,
o quizá no, depende de las razones
para escoger ese tipo de dieta.
Lo que está claro es que la pregunta
que os he hecho al principio
de por qué comemos carne
está encima de la mesa,
y los problemas de sostenibilidad
no van a desaparecer,
ni tampoco las necesidades
que tenemos como especie.
Esta es la carne menos contaminante
que se ha hecho en el mundo.
La podéis llamar como queráis,
tiene varios nombres:
carne cultivada, carne 'in vitro',
'clean meat' en EEUU, carne ética...
Pero lo que está claro es que va a llegar
a los lineales del supermercado,
la vais a tener disponible,
o un familiar o un amigo
os la va a poner en la mesa,
y entonces vais a tener
la capacidad y la posibilidad de elegir.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)